-Every major Democrat
in the country
has called on the governor
of Virginia to resign
after racist photos surfaced
from his medical-school
yearbook.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just to give you some context,
you might recall that, in 2017,
the Virginia governor's race
was one of the first
major electoral tests
of the Trump era.
And it revolved, in large part,
on issues of race.
For example, there was a debate
about the state's
Confederate monuments
with Republican candidate
Ed Gillespie
arguing to keep them
in order to educate people.
-Our history is our history.
And I believe that we need
to educate about it
and that we need
to teach about it.
And so, my view is that
the statues should remain,
and we should place them
in historical context
so that people can learn.
We don't have to glorify
the objects of the statues.
We can educate about them.
-Who uses statues to learn?
Read a book, watch a film,
talk to an expert.
I never see kids
standing in Columbus Circle
staring at the statue because
they have a test the next day.
[ Laughter ]
"I got a quiz in an hour,
stone man!
Talk to me!"
[ Laughter ]
The only thing
I've ever learned from a statue
is that pigeons all have IBS.
[ Laughter ]
Not only are Confederate statues
symbols of slavery
and white supremacy,
they're also ugly.
I mean, this is an actual statue
of Confederate general
Nathan Bedford Forrest.
I mean, look at his face!
[ Laughter ]
Is that the face he made
when he lost the Civil War
or when he walked in
on his parents having sex?
[ Laughter ]
Or both!
"Mother, Father,
I have terrible news!
Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
So, that was the context
for the Virginia election,
which was won by the Democratic
candidate, Ralph Northam.
But now, just over a year later,
virtually every major Democrat
in the country
is calling on Northam to resign
after his own racist past
surfaced on Friday.
-Calls are getting louder
this evening
for Democratic Virginia governor
Ralph Northam to resign
after these racist photos
from 1984 surfaced just today.
-A decades-old yearbook page
suddenly
in the spotlight tonight
because of this picture
of two people,
one in blackface,
the other in a KKK hood.
The page
belongs to Ralph Northam.
He's now the Democratic governor
of Virginia.
That's him in the tie in 1984,
the year he graduated from the
Eastern Virginia Medical School.
-Northam has apologized
but has not said which one
was him in that picture.
-Wow.
That's a real lose-lose.
[ Laughter ]
That's like being asked whether
you're Erik or Lyle Menendez.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Does it matter?
I'm no professor
of political science,
but it's not good
when you have to specify
whether you're the one
in blackface
or the one in the KKK robe.
There's no good option here.
Even the curtain
in the background of that photo
had to hold a press conference
to apologize.
[ Laughter ]
Also, this was in a yearbook?
How do you even sign
a yearbook like that?
"Too racist to be forgotten"?
[ Laughter ]
'Course, it was a yearbook
for medical school,
so it would probably
be impossible to read.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you would think this would
be pretty straightforward.
If you're caught doing something
that horrific
and your entire party
tells you to quit,
you resign, end of story.
And yet somehow, the story got
worse as the weekend went on.
In less than 24 hours,
Northam went from admitting
he was in the photo
and apologizing for it
to claiming it wasn't him.
-When it surfaced Friday on
the website Big League Politics,
condemnation from fellow
Democrats came hard and fast.
Northam acknowledged the photo
and apologized twice,
saying it does not represent
the person I am today.
-Less than 24 hours later,
he said
he was absolutely certain
and he never believed that it
was him in that picture.
-When I was confronted
with the images yesterday,
I was appalled
that they appeared on my page.
But I believe then and now
that I am not either
of the people in that photo.
Last night,
I finally had a chance
to sit down and look at
the photograph in detail.
It is definitely not me.
I can tell by looking at it.
I recognize that many people
will find this difficult
to believe.
-Oh, do you?
[ Laughter ]
You're telling us
that a racist photo surfaced,
and your first instinct
was to say, "Yeah, that's me,"
but then you looked closer
and realized it wasn't?
[ Laughter ]
Shouldn't even be a question.
Most normal people,
if you asked them,
did you ever wear blackface
or a KKK robe,
would go "Absolutely not!
That's insane!"
But your reaction was,
"Well, what was the prom theme?"
[ Laughter ]
And yet Northam's defense got
even worse and more convoluted.
He tried to claim that he knows
it's not him in the photo
because there was another time
when he did wear blackface,
and he remembers that time
very clearly.
-My belief
that I did not wear that costume
or attend that party
stems in part
from my clear memory
of other mistakes I made
in this same period of my life.
That same year,
I did participate
in a dance contest
in San Antonio,
in which I darkened my face
as part
of a Michael Jackson costume.
It is because my memory
of that episode is so vivid
that I truly do not believe I am
in the picture in my yearbook.
-He's actually arguing
that it couldn't
have been him in blackface
because there was a different
time he wore blackface.
[ Laughter ]
It's not a defense.
That's a confession.
Try that next time
a cop pulls you over.
"Officer, I'm totally sober.
Usually when I drive drunk,
I swerve a lot more."
[ Laughter ]
Even if it's not you
in that photo,
admitting that you did wear
blackface at a different event
is also disqualifying.
It's not just
an embarrassing story,
it's racist and dehumanizing.
And yet the press conference,
believe it or not,
got much, much worse because
Northam then went into detail
about how he won
the dance contest...
[ Laughter ]
...and a reporter later
followed up with a question
that provoked one of
the more cringe-worthy moments
in recent political history.
-It was a dance contest.
I had
always liked Michael Jackson.
I actually won the contest,
because I had learned
how to do the moonwalk.
-You said that the competition
in San Antonio
was a dance competition?
-Yes.
-And it was that
you danced the moonwalk?
-That's right.
-Are you still able to moonwalk?
-Oh.
-Inappropriate circumstances.
-My wife says,
"Inappropriate circumstances."
-Look at his face!
He actually thought
about doing it!
[ Laughter ]
That is the face of a man
looking to see if he has room
to moonwalk!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I can't believe --
I can't believe anyone
has to say this,
but you can't moonwalk
your way out of this one.
[ Laughter ]
His wife was pretty quick
on the draw, though.
"Inappropriate circumstances,"
right away.
Obviously,
this isn't the first time
she's had to stop him
from moonwalking.
[ Laughter ]
"You know, it's so good
to be here this christening.
You know, I think
if Michael Jackson was here --"
"No, Ralph!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'm gonna guess
that reporter
changed his question on the fly.
"Man, I know I should ask about
his plans to stay in office,
but I really want to see
if I can make him moonwalk!"
[ Laughter ]
So, how old were the guys
who finished second and third
to him in a dance contest?
[ Laughter ]
Now, the response from Democrats
has been nearly unanimous.
Basically, every major Democrat
in the state of Virginia
and Washington
and across the country
has called on Northam to resign,
and yet at least one Republican
tried to use the Northam scandal
against Democrats.
Donald Trump Jr.
reposted a tweet
from Senator Kamala Harris,
congratulating Northam on his
victory two years ago that said,
"Congratulations
to Ralph Northam and his team
for showing that Virginia won't
stand for hatred and bigotry."
Don Jr. added,
"Well, this is awkward
and didn't age well at all."
You might not want to comment
on what's awkward
and not aging well.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your dad --
Your dad is the birther
who proposed a Muslim ban
and said Nazis are fine people,
so maybe sit this one out,
Grease Frightening.
[ Laughter ]
Every major Democrat
in the country
has called on Northam to resign.
He should listen to them.
Staying on at this point
would be --
-Inappropriate circumstances.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]